draftkings has the wind total set the
Packers are over-under nine wins you
know I've seen it as low as eight and a
half and the first time I saw it I
thought what in the world did did Aaron
Rodgers retire and they just haven't
announced it yet what do they know that
we don't know doesn't 9 seem too low for
this team even though 13 and 3 may have
been a little bit of an aberration last
year well I am one of those that
believes that you know 13 and 3 was a
little bit of an aberration last year I
will state that clearly you know again
it this is a good football team do I sit
here and go ooh they were dominant no I
think it was a good football team with a
great quarterback who knew how to close
out games with teams that were equal to
or lesser than them and they didn't let
any really wins get out of their grasp
really per se or for lack of a better
phrase but you know if you go back and
look at their 2019 schedule it's pretty
favorable hey the good thing is for at
least for me and like within the nine
win conversation yeah I think if I sit
here right now I think I expect Green
Bay to be above nine wins but I don't
know how much more than that bike I mean
you know one
what have they really done to improve
the roster you know so I don't know if I
love that they are gonna be playing a
first place schedule this year that's
gonna be different but I don't view them
as a team to go back to being a 13 and
win football team I guess is what I'm
saying
I think I look at it as maybe ten and
six eleven and five the good thing for
them I think is their division I don't
think got incredibly better either
Minnesota stayed somewhat similar
Detroit yeah they got better and
collected some New England players but
I'm not born out of the water the same
thing with the Bears to where I still
look at Green Bay and go I think they're
the best team in the division clearly
that the Vikings have lost some key
players Everson Griffin a free agent who
I guess in theory could still return to
Minnesota depending upon what happens
elsewhere although they don't have the
cap space to give him a significant
contract Stefon Diggs was traded right
before the free agency period officially
opened that was a surprise although not
completely unexpected
but you go younger at that position with
Justin Jefferson you're right dice that
that that player is going to be able to
step in and make a difference
across madam Phelan has to do something
in that offense so there's a lot of
question marks for that Vikings team a
blend of definitely of young players and
established players and they're gonna
have to make it work quickly without the
benefit of an offseason program there at
eight and a half wins and one piece of
news from over the weekend safety
Anthony Harris has accepted his
franchise tender so he's with the team
this year at eleven point four million
dollars he's eight and a half wins what
do you know you have you can't you can't
call a push on this one it's over or
under what do you think with the Vikings
at eight and a half well I you know you
hit on all the key points you talked
about some of the offensive players are
missing too
you know I mean the defense is gonna be
a lot different you know you've course
you mentioned ever sing graphing but no
tre Wayne's no Xavier Rhodes no
Mackenzie Alexander and the secondary
anymore so that's gonna be a different
thing and especially with Minnesota
Vikings and Mike Zimmer and he's the
defensive genius I mean you know how
comfortable is some of these new young
players gonna be in the scheme how smart
are they so I don't know I still look at
Minnesota as going there a playoff
caliber football team you know your
Vikings are solvent I don't sit here
though and go oh man no this is a
Superbowl caliber team I look at them as
yeah that fringe playoff who they could
be dangerous and win a game in the
playoffs but that's about it type of
team and yeah I think you know as I sit
here and look at their schedule uh it's
gonna be tough it's gonna be tough I
think to replicate what you did last
year and that success you know Green Bay
Colts Tennessee Titans Houston Texans
Seattle Seahawks for your first got five
games of the year I think we'll have a
good feel for what the Minnesota Vikings
will be after that little stretch and
how serious we'll take them as
contenders yeah I mean the Packers and
Aaron Rodgers right out of the mance and
you mentioned all of the defensive backs
who are gone whether they were cut or
whether they left as free agents and I
scroll through the cornerbacks here and
we look at the when you look at the
experience it's a lot of two one and our
meaning years of experience for these
guys and a lot of our rookie rookie
Rookie
guys they drafted they hope they can get
up to speed
yeah and something Mike Zimmer said last
week that he's not really into the idea
of joint practices this year in training
camp because he's got to focus on
getting his guys ready forget about
trying to practice against other teams
we got to get these guys ready we got to
teach them technique we got to show them
how to write football players we got it
we got it we got to make them prepared
to face where they're gonna be facing in
the NFL and Zimmer is very good about
coaching up defensive backs but I think
this is gonna be one of his toughest
challenges because for a lot of these
guys he's starting from scratch getting
through to them what it's going to take
to properly defend against the highest
level of passing attacks that the NFL
can provide because they're gonna be
playing a lot of teams with great
quarterbacks this year man I mean really
are I mean you look at it and go Aaron
Rodgers Phillip Rivers Tannehill Watson
Russell Wilson Matt Ryan back to Aaron
Rodgers in your first seven games of the
year
I mean that's real deal you're right
that's gonna be quite the test on that
young secondary let alone Everson
Griffin's not there like you mentioned
to wear it that helps the secondary out
when a guy like that a freak of nature
is running around the edge making the
quarterback have to throw the ball
quicker that'll make the secondary look
a lot better so yeah there's some
there's some questions there with the
Minnesota football team I mean I just I
don't know you tell me Mike I mean I
just think the NFC North is
underwhelming as is the only thing I
look at at the end of the NFC North is
like a bright shiny object is like okay
Aaron Rodgers you know and then maybe
that Bears defense other than that you
know is there a lot of a leap to go
around to the NFC North I'm not so sure
about that
bears are at seven and a half wins over
under and the Lions are at seven I I got
a I got a hard time believing that
either team is gonna go over with the
Bears who knows who knows what the Bears
are one of those rollercoaster teams
where when the expectations are high
they fail when the expectations are low
they thrive right so the expectations
are low this year if so facto they're
gonna thrive the Lions just continue
whatever the bar is they continue to
find a way to just run right under it
well the Bears gotta find an identity as
a football team you know last year it's
like they were trying to be like the
Kansas City Chiefs on offense with the
85 Bears on defense and that's not
cohesive
making a team or winning football games
especially on the offensive side of the
ball but hey if you're the Chicago Bears
and I know you got Matt Nagy and he came
from Kansas City and you want this
high-flying boss I'd say that's sure
that's great you don't have Patrick
mahomes and some of the weapons it's not
going to happen but what you do have is
a borderline Super Bowl caliber defense
so play through that and I think that's
where they really messed up last year so
the Bears yet seven wins hey I could sit
here and see that but I won't sit here
and be shocked that the Bears ended up
like ten and six either because I think
if they played the game the right way
and get better and you know playing more
physical on offense run the football a
little bit I mean one of the worst
running teams and football last year
they're running scheme stink to go along
with it it's very simple and I don't
care how good your defense is you know
Khalil Mack Danny Trevathan Hakeem it's
it's hard to be really awesome and
dominate a game when you're out there
every four plays because your offense
can't get a first down or do anything so
that to me is where the Bears have to
change to and if they can play that way
and find that formula to play through
their defense and ball control and do
that they could be one of those teams to
like what you're saying Mike that's an
ugly ten and six football team that won
a lot of games 17 to 13 or 20 to 17 I
wouldn't be shocked with that they've
made some good improvements to their
roster
I like the Colca meta tight end Jimmy
Graham a tight end they're making it
look like they're gonna try to play a
tougher brand on off a tougher brand of
football on the offensive side but we'll
see and of course the quarterback issue
is a big big concern in Chicago well and
look to the extent that they decided to
make Nick falls the newcomer and Matt
Negi said last week that for Falls
learning that offense just like riding a
bike he knows that offense I'd go back
to the playoff run for Philadelphia in
2017 the playoff run in 2018 which
included a trip to Chicago and an upset
of the Bears who had won the division
with a 12 and four record I would just
do what the Eagles did with Nick falls
right they had a they had a defense that
was good enough and Nick Foles made it
happen
put your faith in Nick Foles and tell
him go do it once you've acquired him
you've youth that's what you've signed
on for it's the Don Shula advice that
still resonates with Kevin Kolbert the
Stila GM to this day
if you have red paint paint your barn
red you've got Nick Foles
do what Nick Foles has done well in the
past that is what you're hitching your
wagon to for 2020 and if they can pull
that off they can have more than seven
and a half winds Chris yeah they
definitely could and you know again I
think they should start Nick Foles to
start the year bare barring something
crazy to happen I just think the the
spotlight the scrutiny if you start your
Brisky will be too much to handle it'll
be a disruption for the football team
the first time he throws an incompletion
the fans Ubu put Nick Foles in there
just start Nick Foles your right front
and find a brand of or a style of
offense that fits fits falls he's big
you know he can he's really fearless in
the pocket if you could run the ball
he'll take care of the ball and he'll
make some plays down the field and
that'll be interesting and then you know
hey Mack we didn't hit on Detroit much
but Detroit we know this is a huge year
for their organization and their
football team Bob Quinn Matt Patricia I
mean we know their butts are coming out
on the hot seat Matt Stafford is this
his last year there you know we saw the
culture change last year and we saw some
positives and then max Taffer got hurt
and it all kind of went down the toilet
that way but you know I just don't know
what to expect from the Detroit Lions I
guess is what I'm saying and my attitude
with the Lions until they prove me wrong
I'm not gonna expect anything my
expectations are just they don't exist I
have no expectations for the Lions I've
been aware of this team for 50 years and
other than some periodic
you know blips it's been nothing and you
know I'm not saying they're gonna be bad
I'm not saying they're gonna be good I'm
just saying I expect nothing and let's
just see that Lions can do this
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports